let's let's let's do this too um i got
the story out of upi russian warplanes
violate sweden's airspace
reportedly uh sweden's air force
dispatched jas 39 gripen aircraft in
response to two russian su-27s and two
su-24s briefly entering its airspace
east of gotland island in the baltic sea
we also have reports japan says a
russian helicopter violated its airspace
and scrambled fighter jets to give you
context on the the uh the sheer size of
russia we come over here to uh we got
google earth pulled up here's japan
right it's russia right here there's
vladivostok and so you've got these
islands we're talking about what 50 to
100 miles away from japan that's russia
if we zoom out and go all the way across
russia over to europe check it out not
only do you have moscow right here with
finland you have kaliningrad which is
right here it's an oblast and this is
scotland so russia
is massive on top of that let's just go
over here and point at the fact that
russia is 50 miles from the united
states so
they got a lot they're they're spread
out very thin
it doesn't mean that uh
they can win
but it does mean that they can reach
many different people very very quickly
and if russia's been preparing this for
some time
they can easily move troops and
armaments into various regions
arguably like
acro like very close to many different
countries you'd expect to be on the
other side of the planet
without anyone knowing or at the very
least without setting off alarm bells
and pissing anybody off it's their own
country it's russia so they put troops
in the east and the west and they can
effectively be ready to fight on you
know all spheres of the [ __ ]
and one of the things that jack was just
talking about when it comes to the
arctic is we've been watching the
ukraine build up for a long time the
troop built up on the ukraine border for
a long time the the putin's army buildup
in in the arctic has been massive it
gets very little coverage and the ones
who are the most afraid of the
norwegians because they are they're not
members of nato right they're not i
don't believe they're even part of the
eu um they're the largest oil and gas
producer up there but russia is saying
no no no this is this is ours the arctic
is ours right and there's a reason why
clearly they want the arctic um they
have they are building enormous and have
built enormous uh lng ports along their
north coast in terms of export lng now
directly to to the world in terms of
military force i mean it's it's it's
pretty clear that russia does have a
strong
command presence when it comes to the
arctic at this point the united states i
think only has one icebreaker at this
point and it's it's only you know it's
kind of in uh you know it's always stuck
in the ice it's always easy yeah yeah
very good
but it's like
it's barely you know barely works very
well china has a ton of ice cutters but
of course uh china does not have any
actual access to the arctic so if china
this is another part of that
relationship this burgeoning
relationship that we're seeing between
china and russia if china wants access
to the arctic they've got to go through
russia if russia wants their financial
backstop they need to go to china the
one you kick them off swift well one
belt one road is right there for you so
but you know ian in answer to your
question if i want to curb these you
know excessive and obviously aggressive
and insane behaviors of the russian
government you know you can say all
right we're going to try to put
sanctions on russia but obviously
they've priced that into this
proposition
how we tried putting sanctions or using
economic leverage on china on the
oligarchs of the ccp on ccp leaders
going after them going after the yuan
using anything that we can there because
obviously china and china and the united
states do not have a strong trade
relationship we never really have but
china and the united states oh yeah
obviously russia you said china first
excuse me russia in the united states
russian united states you think that's
just because we don't have sea routes
and we're not right because china and
the ice is kind of right next to each
other i mean i guess the russians and
the americans do have see plenty of sea
connections we just they just don't have
much to trade what is it why why are
they not a great trade trade leader
they're so massive that's what i'm at
who why the russians russia and america
not trade is it just because it's like
uninhabitable most of russia well most
of russia is uninhabitable that those
the you're yes on a map it's it's
massive but a lot of that area is either
unused or it's not arable or they just
don't have the people the population to
putin was trying to hire you know
farmers for siberia at one point or like
recruit people to come in and oh yeah
give them a place for free as long as
they work the land right they were
talking about bringing you know the
south african farmers up there as a way
to you know get away from the issues
they were facing the farm murders down
in south africa but
um yeah for the majority of that area
right you're you're really only looking
at it in terms of resources and
when it comes to those resources as
daniel of course would be able to
explain much better than me um and knows
what's better than me you know we are
competitors in those areas yeah it's
pretty terrifying to think of the 21st
century and all those resources in
russia with with the uh with the actual
amount of power russia has which is not
that much
and the amount of land there and that's
just very very very much
that's why the currency stuff doesn't
hit them the way that we would expect it
to because they still have the resources
but i would disagree with saying that
they're not that powerful they're
they're they have what like 60 of the
military capability of the entirety of
nato
and that's that's it's it's such yeah
they have different type yeah they have
they have a different different types
more nukes absolutely but i mean
they are they are our largest we are
their largest customer for fertilizer
right around 800 million dollars a year
in fertilizer that now probably we're
not going to buy
what are we going to do
it's we live in a rural area you're
getting ready to harvest in a couple of
weeks what are you putting on your field
you need about 100 pounds of fertilizer
per acre
so if i have a 5 000 acre corn field
what am i
so do i just lose the crop so i have to
buy it from somewhere else so what a
corn price is going to do what are we
price we prices have already doubled so
what are food so i mean we're worried
about well the price at the pump and i
am i'm an energy guy i'm worried about
the price of the pump i'm worried this
november i can't imagine what food
prices are going to be and you want to
see violence yo wait till people already
hungry i might have misheard you you
said i thought you said we sell them no
we're going to buy from buy fertilizer
from them yeah no we buy from no this is
the same and it's the serving that we
buy it's a serving that we buy someone
you know it's disturbing that it might
get cut off it's disturbing that we buy
our pharmaceuticals from china and that
is what i hate about globalism who has
outs who decided who's the brain trust
that said let's put these things in the
hands of our enemies let's let's just
let's just point out
how moronic the leadership of this
country has been outsourcing to china
then we get covered what does china do
they have their citizens across around
the world buy up ppe and ship it back to
china we don't make our own medicine you
have to be a special kind of stupid to
outsource to china and then pick a fight
with with with russia who is going to be
who's going to be working with china so
now we're in this position where like
you brought up fertilizer but we've also
got vitamin c antibiotics now you get
biden coming out in the state of union
address being like we're going to be
investing in these these chips for your
computer chips and he's basically
signaling
war may be coming and we will lose
taiwan i can and i can verify that first
thing you said in case anyone thinks
that you're lying um which you never
would or you're misrepresenting the
truth married to an australian in
november of 19 andrew said i was talking
to my mind he's from a rural town in the
outback and said my mom said the
weirdest thing happened like she was at
the grocery and this bus of of some
chinese people got up and they bought
everything she said like what the heck
was that she said and and then like
neighbors talk this is november of 19 he
was saying it's so weird everyone i
talked to in my little town says a van
of chinese people will show up and they
will buy everything in the store and it
will disappear it was reported that and
that was
the beginning of so they're getting
china told their citizens in other
countries to buy ppe and send it and
send it back yeah well it's interesting
because we've been talking a little bit
about nuclear weaponry and mutually
assured
destruction one thing not a lot of
people consider is that biological
weaponry is also considered to be a
weapon or a form of a weapon of mass
destruction and china literally created
one and released it i know that there's
still some debate around that
technically but i think it's pretty
straightforward and so
i would say yeah well it's so lab league
but if a country accidentally detonated
a nuke in another nation
i don't mean
nature of our leadership
for fouchy to be working in any way with
any groups that we're working with china
you are you are you are working with a
group that despises you yeah the chinese
communist party does not like
us
they want to displace us they've
insulted us they they
outright say they want to take taiwan
they press the south china sea they sink
vietnamese ships this is not a country
we should be like let's give them more
stuff let's give them more access more
resources more more more authority and
and it's just the sheer absurdity of the
us
picking a fight while giving things away
is it's the craziest thing so
i suppose the neoliberal idea is that if
we build trade lines we won't go to well
that was it that was that was that was
just
that was clinton
golden arches golden arches theories is
a version of it the idea that two
nations that have mcdonald's have never
gone to war with each other it's not
true well and it also
it's interesting because it is the case
that countries that stop trading with
each other are more likely to go to war
libertarians
yeah uh but that said yeah i mean a huge
part of this i think it's just
indicative of our total inability to
defer gratification as a people so
there's this country that we're trying
to pick fights with while at the same
time still giving away our resources to
them because there's a short-term gain
for it in it for us we're not actually
thinking about a long-term strategy here
when they very much are i wouldn't say
that not trading with the country makes
you more likely to go war with them i
don't think that's a fair oh that's fair
i'm saying there's i'm not okay that's
fair but trading with the country
it's not great
they were saying it the other way around
that if you trade it creates a
disincentive to go this is what we were
told in the 90s when we gave china most
favored nation status under clinton
right as they begin to grow
and and become a trading partner and as
they get a taste of it we'll open them
up and
very bizarre almost marks this idea that
the way we solve people's problems is
just by increasing access to resources
or building wealth and it's an issue of
materialism yeah so we do see it with
hyper capitalist uh ideologies as well
but they they meld together very it's
very ironic because people see like
hyper capitalism and communism as being
diametrically opposed but the reality is
this idea that we can solve people's
problems simply through materialism and
that they will become more evolved and
better people because their wealth has
grown is obviously completely backwards
and we're seeing the effects of that now
with china look at what we did in
afghanistan we gave them all ipads but
they don't have internet materials like
well there you go congratulations guys i
think we need the us government to
heavily invest in some kind of
public infrastructure for protecting the
american people from nuclear war
perhaps we could build big underground i
don't know vaults
and uh we call the company something
related that like vault uh tech
vault-tec vault-tec vault-tec like
technology we would number eight
in order to communicate could we have
certain armbands yes as an example
absolutely like a good computer
or something like that what would you
even call something like that
now since the us dollar is going
completely
or something you know since the us
dollar is going out of is being devalued
what could we use as currency in this
situation i don't know
oh hey no no i actually have an idea the
most logical answer to that question
would be hold on a bottle caps
i can't think of anything else
a metal down
[Music]
when jack said we could wear something
on her wrists and fallout you have the
pit boy and the pip boy shows your
health status i'm literally wearing a
woo you're pretty close yeah yeah yeah
pull up my hair
my heart rate and stuff but it doesn't
have the graphics but check it out when
when i was getting sick the whoop knew i
was sick before i knew i was sick of
course and so did google of course
whoever owns that so did jeff bezos yeah
the chinese found out gets his daily tim
pool report jeff bezos is like he like
wakes up and he goes to grab his coffee
and then he like opens a tap and he goes
oh tim's sick dude wouldn't it be
hilarious if there was just this long
con
uh sabotaging or like this idea of
warfare where the companies that own
that uh ip are actually like selling it
to china and china ever so tweaked like
all right i know this is healthy form
we're going to tell him to do the less
healthy thing instead of the thing
that's morally for him because we're
going to weaken him as a person
people didn't really laugh when you said
that that's kind of freakishly possible
do you think so
people drive into swamps because their
google maps tell them
i think it's possible that people would
listen to that absolutely if you're
watching i'm half joking though about
this
tiny little thing yeah
before guys before we get too far off
this so
the the nuclear plant situation ton of
um this is a tweet from ilya lozovsky
the actual nuclear specialists are
coming out of the woodwork to say that
no we would not see a marvel movie style
explosion yes it is bad fuel could leak
there could be radiation that comes out
of that but let's not retweet government
pronouncements uncritically it is a
different kind of reactor than chernobyl
uh you can scram it you can shut do
emergency shutdowns the concrete shells
they have on this thing are capable of
being hit by aircraft weighing 20 tons
and not going um you know not melting
down and it's ian you and i were just
talking about this before you know the
reason chernobyl melted down is because
they were running a test and the test
went crazy it wasn't just some uh random
fire that broke out and then it you know
ignited it and chernobyl because it
exploded it shot nuclear fissile
material into the atmosphere i believe
and then it blanketed the area so like
carbon if if the corium just melts it
just falls into the earth it just falls
down and then hits the cement and then
melts through the cement and keeps
melting through the ground until right
so we are not so fortunately for
everybody out there you know it crazy as
it is you are not in a situation where
this thing could melt down over this hey
they turn the chat on it looks like oh
no okay no they stopped it i see the
stream ended they did have a chat oh
they saw the stream
yeah
but does that have the chat up disabled
the chat is disabled
oh i still have a chat going but maybe
it's they disabled the chat for the
nuclear fire fight it i can't tell
can you imagine can you imagine i mean
the abcs are still there the artillery
is still there
can you imagine like if we were able to
document other historic events like this
if we were able to watch live streams
that had occurred of like events in
world war ii and see the chat pickets
charged and a lot of people were just
like yeah i still have a chat on mine
you get more really oh you're on a
different one
yeah someone else has aggregated a bunch
of live feeds at hastings.com like oh
he's arrived right william's here well i
i wonder if the charge is a light
brigade i wonder i wonder how much of it
would just be like crazy insane memes
too because that's i feel like what's
gonna be today no no it was i was
talking about this the mega mines
ukrainians with massive balls meme and
i'm like it was a really garbage meme
but you've got intelligence agencies
spamming pro-ukraine propaganda it works
to a certain degree look at all the
people that have put the ukrainian flags
in their in their twitter profiles i'll
tell you one of the things that really
triggered the establishment the lefty
activists was when i said i noticed
everyone was flying west virginia's
colors i was like it's about time
everyone recognized how awesome the
state is because you know west virginia
university uses blue and gold they got
pissed at me for that i was like why are
you so mad as a joke about the
colors for west virginia
i think they really believe this is like
the end of western civilization this is
like the beginning of the end of western
civilization it's people have been so
freaked out and manipulated by russia
it's i understand the fear of the soviet
union communist nuclear missile crisis
but russia is not the soviet union it's
a federation you can argue there are a
bunch of oligarchs in control over there
as well as you could argue that in
america that there are and in china
apparently oligarchs are running the
show and in ukraine and in ukraine but
but i do love what you said because you
have heard that a lot from politicians
this is an attack on western
civilization we have to defend western
civilization and the first thing i
thought of was if
six weeks ago i said something about
western civilization you would have
called me like a white nationalist yeah
it's true no you're right you're about
to be right you know so now we love
western civilization again you see joe
biden
when he said that the people of ukraine
are fighting for their homeland and
they're like they have an iron will an
iron will and it was lauren the southern
point of that pointed this out she was
like that was like every racist dog
whistle that if trump said that they
would start writing article after
article saying it
so especially her argument was he was
accidentally racist by their own
standards and she's right she's right
yeah absolutely just ignored it so you
know what they're doing by the way with
this they're gonna i guarantee you they
are gonna try to use this nuclear plant
situation
as a way to get a no-fly zone instituted
you watch yeah it's exactly what i can
see this is where it's gonna go they're
going to say turn around and say you
have to institute this because of the
recklessness that we're seeing because
of the shelling and you're going to have
to institute a no-fly zone at what
whatever the cost
i assure you
in the event that happens they're going
to like it to chernobyl they're going to
say the risks of another chernobyl
should never be allowed oh my goodness
so we are instituting a no-fly zone
vladimir putin mark my words i didn't
see chernobyl the movie but was it scare
tactic or was it accurate
there's a tv show wasn't it i thought it
was interesting i thought it was
fantastic i thought it was very well
done actually yeah did it scare people
into like nuclear fear oh big time big
time i mean if you're if you're someone
who's anti-nuclear that's the movie you
want everywhere the the the the
fukushima meltdown scared angela merkel
into cancelling her whole country's
nuclear reactors and you want to say but
germany doesn't have a lot of tsunamis
angela like you you you shouldn't be
worried about that let me tell you
angela merkel if a tsunami hit germany
nuclear fallout is the least
right you got a lot bigger but she shut
down the entire country's nuclear
program now they're buying lng from
russia and they're afraid to sanction
lng that liquid natural gas which is
methane which because
yeah yeah
yeah and because they don't have enough
energy what are there other natural
gases than methane that are
no that's the predominant one is methane
and if you look at germany like the the
amount of coast they have it's not that
much
so
you know where are they shutting down
these nuclear power plants it's just
greta tunberg comes out and she said
those magic words she said how dare you
and everyone just collapsed and grasped
their hearts and
realized how wrong they were for years
we were talking about dan you said i you
and i used to talk about this when we
were doing one american news that it was
always the russians that were funding
these anti-fracking groups for years and
if you turned on so okay they banned rt
right so rt america isn't there i think
they're still up on youtube right now
you can go to rt.com
and uh it was down for a little bit
today well no they're they're so well
let's let's do this but what was
interesting and you know not to get into
the censorship angle but you could see
what russia's strategic interests were
based on the story selection there and a
huge chunk of their programming was
devoted towards green groups was devoted
to anti-fracking was devoted to this
because so then you could watch that and
you could say oh well that's something
that russia wants to push i wonder why
that is and then i talk to a guy who
understands energy you sound like a
lunatic if you said that well just a
couple years ago people were like oh
take your tin foil like oh he wants to
watch rt to find out what the russians
want let me know doesn't that make sense
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 p.m
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you